[Music]
welcome back to the worlds of
speculative fiction series we are now
beginning session 47
of this more or less monthly series that
we began back in 2016
and have continued on even into these
covid times now
doing this uh over the the net
using video premieres and video
conferencing and
things like that eventually someday
we're going to go back to meeting
in libraries the way that we used to and
what we're going to be
exploring this time is a continuation
from last time this is a little bit of a
something new for the series so
we are going through the rest of the
books of earthsea which is a great way
to describe it
available here in this wonderful omnibus
volume
that i was gifted for my 50th birthday
earlier this year by a friend of mine
and so we're looking at books four five
and six in the earthsea
saga you could call it there there was
an earlier
trilogy that we discussed in session 46
uh which begins with a wizard of earth c
centered on the figure
of ged who plays a major role in each of
those
novels introducing additional characters
as well who are going to play an
important role as well
in in these stories too and
so um we're going to be looking at these
these other stories and we're going to
do things a little bit different
in this session so typically with these
worlds of speculative fiction
series um conversations that we've been
having
what we would do is you know go through
the biography
of the author and talk about important
turning points or series or different
you know developments maybe
some critical appreciation of the author
by other speculative fiction authors
then we would jump into some discussion
about world building and the narrative
universe that they have created
and then we'd look at particular
philosophical themes
that are especially interesting or
prominent
within their works and we are going to
do
some of those things we're definitely
going to talk about philosophical themes
for example
in these later books leguin is
positioning herself
somewhat critically and somewhat
uncomfortably in relation to
the you know developing movement of
feminism
um she's also you know thinking about
the nature
of the relations between men and women
in in the the workings of her characters
thoughts and their relationships and
their assumptions
we're going to talk a lot about the
nature of magic in these
stories because it plays a major role
and and it's it's history
we're going to talk about what they
refer to as the balance
and the nature of life and death and
what happens to us
after that we're also going to be
talking about
this theme of identity that gets posed
in the earlier
books and assumes an important role in
in these books
as well and we'll also you know touch on
the relationship between the humans and
dragons
and language we talked about that in
session 46 as well and we may
be able to smuggle in some other
philosophical themes in addition to
these
we'll see how much we're able to do that
it's always a matter of time i don't
like these videos to go longer than
90 minutes and i'm usually just you know
presenting them
with a few notes and then you know going
to the books and talking about what's
what's going on so it's rather
unpredictable we never know exactly
what we're going to get we're not going
to do a biography
because we already did a biography for
ursula k le guin
back in the you know session 46
uh and earlier in the very first
year of this series where we looked at
le guin's
science fiction novels and what it's
called the highness cycle
so we don't need to do that but i
thought it would be useful to go into
a bit of why she wrote these books at
the time that she did and we're going to
look at you know what she has to say
about it
very conveniently she has some
discussion of that
in in the this volume itself
so we'll do a bit of biography and then
we'll
we'll also talk a lot about world
building
because you know what's going on in the
following volumes is
you can think of it as an expansion and
in her own view
an exploration and unfolding
of this world of earth-sea that that she
created
you know decades before she's adding
more to the picture there's
there's even a map in here and she talks
about you know exploring the places
on the map you know having her
characters go there and then find out
what's actually
going on so there's nice map here in the
beginning
you can easily find maps online of
earthsea
as well so you can you know probably get
a better looking map
just by going to to the net so
you know these these new stories
are coming out you could say
really in a 11 year period tahanu
is published in 1990 so you could say
there's some writing going on before
that
then there's tales of earth sea which is
the fifth volume
that is coming out in 2001 and also in
2001 another novel which which brings
everything to
more or less a successful close the
other wind
and that is is sort of the end of the
evolution
of earth sea and so as opposed to the
the early trilogy which is
three novels you know following in
succession
right get as a young man get going to
the tombs of atuan introducing the new
character arya the
the eaten one who is uh you know
tahanu as well um you know
though those two sort of get as as in
his prime and then get
as an older mage uh in
in the uh the third volume bringing in a
new character
right who's going to become the he's at
that time a prince
becomes the new king in hovnor
um as opposed to that what we have here
is a set of other um
novels and the novels are are so the
novels are the fourth and the sixth book
right tahanu and the other wind and they
are set
in the time after uh
the events of the furthest shore after
ged has
lost his his capacities and
there is a new king being being crowned
and now
new crises being faced both those
political and those of
we could call it magic or or
wisdom and power
but the other the tales of earthsea what
we have there
are five short stories and these
are spanning a very long time
indeed they are not all
happening at the same time they're
filling in a lot of backstory
including a good bit of how things got
to be the way they are
in this magical island of roque
which we we should talk about in just a
moment we'll do a little bit of review
of
of the the world that leguin has
sketched out here
so we have several different stories the
finder
which is quite long and and talks uh
quite a bit about a time when
magic was you could say in many respects
less disciplined less ethical
uh people were sort of finding their way
dark rose
and diamond the bones of the earth which
is about
ged's own teacher oguion
when he was a younger man
on the high marsh and
then we have dragonfly and and
in addition to that towards the end of
this
omnibus volume was published in
in the fifth volume something that i
think those who like to geek out on
you know world building um something
quite quite
useful uh for for all of us and that
is i'm trying to find it right here um
before all of these these stories here
we go a description
of earth sea and it's not a short
description
liguin provides us with
all sorts of discussions about earth
seas
history languages writing
some of the you know the the important
kings and
mages and
what's going on with with different
peoples
how wizardry was established
all of those sorts of background things
she she doesn't give us a ton of
information there just enough to
fill in some gaps and tantalize us
you know there's a lot that's left open
to the imagination
in in le guin's work so before we go
into
looking at why she
says she wrote these particular works
in the way that she did let's take a
look at the afterword that she has here
this is at the end
of the other wind and she's talking
about this entire
volume itself so she says here at last
for the first time
is earthsy in english all together in
the right
order and so you know if you do want to
you know
read through all of the earth sea stuff
it couldn't
hurt to get this particular copy but you
could also piece it together just as
well
in any way that you'd like and she
continues by saying
you know the six books of earthsea were
published over
31 years by four different hardcover
publishers
in various paperback editions it still
gets called a trilogy here
though it hasn't been won since 1990
with the publication of tahanu
the fourth book and in england one
publisher calls it a quartet
another reversed the order of the fifth
and sixth books as if it didn't
matter that's publishers right and she
says i think of the books
not as a trilogy or a sextet
a series or cycle but simply as earthsy
now isn't that interesting to to think
about you could arrange them if you
wanted to in a very you know strict
chronological order you could actually
take
all of the short stories uh those that
that she wrote earlier like the rule of
names
and all the ones in um you know the
tales of earthsea and lay them all out
in some sort of
uh sequential order you could come up
with a timeline if you wanted to she
doesn't think that's necessary
she she's thinking of this less just in
terms of chronology
and you could say more in a spatial
or relational fashion she says
if we must have technicalities and if
fantasy must occur in threes we could
call
it the earth c trilogies in the plural
perhaps right she's got a question mark
there
that at least acknowledges the
difference between the first three books
and the last three and then here
she gives us some insight into her own
views
on how the first three books are in some
respects different
than these these final three she says
by market definition the first three are
young adult novels and the last three
aren't
young adult however like most marketing
categories really defines nothing but
books written specifically
to fit it young adult stories have
adolescent protagonists so is romeo and
julio
juliet a young adult should huckleberry
finn be
read only by people huck's age i wrote a
wizard of earthsea to meet the
publisher's request for a book for
younger readers and i gave the next two
books a central character who is a
genuine
authentic young adult ged is only 19 at
the end of a wizard and tanar
and aaron are probably not even that old
at the end of their books
but in the tombs ghett is at least 30
and middle aged in the farther shore and
with tahanu i broke all together from
such constraints of category
i said to myself so here we get laguin
herself you know declaring
her views i said to myself
people who like fantasy read fantasy no
matter what
age either the readers or the characters
are 19 year olds read
the lord of the rings 89 year olds
reread alice in wonderland
i want to follow my characters out of
adolescence
into their whole lives and i trust my
readers to follow them
with me so you know tenner for example
is you know a young woman in the tombs
of ottawa
and she's middle-aged
maybe a little bit past middle-aged
woman in
the fourth and sixth novels right the
tahanu
and the other wind
so she says in tahana there's no
adolescence at all
therau is a little girl 10 are a
middle-aged woman get a middle-aged man
then came the tales about people of
extremely varied ages
finally in the other wind no principal
character is under 20 except for the
princess
cecil rock while tenor is grey-haired
and ged a man
of 70. i was writing my main characters
through my own life and their lives and
they were
long rich lives i'm grateful to my
readers
for living those lives with them
and then she says i'm also grateful for
having been able to write this book or
as i would prefer to put it for the gift
of this story and i think this is a
really great insight into
her own writing and world building she
says such a gift is always a mystery to
a writer
in some way the story itself remains
mysterious
to me you know and this leads us into a
little bit of a discussion of world
building there's there's often a
contrast between
authors who have everything sort of
mapped out ahead of time and which
character is going to do what
and you know sometimes down to the level
of inventing entire languages for them
tolkien
being sort of the um you could say
archetype
of that called the architect versus the
gardener george r martin likes that one
to talk about
you know i just sort of you know plant
the seeds and water it and see what
comes up
and the green is definitely more along
those lines of of gardening and tending
and seeing
what happens she says i can see now its
theme coming together from elements of
all the previous books
joining forces playing out in a way i
could never have foreseen when i started
a wizard of earthsea
even when i started the other wind all i
knew certainly was that the increasing
imbalance
in the practice of wizardry was caused
by a profound error
made long ago and that not only cobb in
the farthest shore
the third book right but thorian of rock
embodied this misunderstanding of the
uses of power the desire for control and
the nature of death that was my
great theme she goes on and says to find
its resolution i had to play it through
writing itself is an action
of playing it through finding out what
the characters
are going to understand what what
mistakes they're going to make what
resolutions they're going to
attain she goes on and she says
i knew partly what i wanted to say not
till it was said did i know
fully and a little bit later you know
this is quite good she says i don't and
won't attempt to explain what it says
i've been asked a thousand times to say
what a story means
every time i've grown sure that so long
as i've told the story rightly finding
its meaning
or a meaning is rightly up to its
readers
so you know this is a very inviting way
of composing and
thinking about character development
thinking about narrative plot thinking
about
setting thinking about world building
thinking about
articulating the relations between
people and what what matters to them
their
loves their fears their
angers their their crimes their their
deaths their
you know retributions all of these sorts
of things um
she's you know in effect created an
alternate
world and done so in a way that invites
us to explore it
with the characters and this is you know
sort of waxing philosophical here you
know many other authors do this
quite well as well in their own
different ways
in the the realm of speculative fiction
and even outside of speculative fiction
in other in history in
um you know other types of uh
fiction in creative non-fiction as well
with writing essays
there's an invitation to the reader to
enter
into the world composed through words
and to you know linger
to to engage in evaluation not just to
be a
passive spectator that's not to say that
you can't be a passive spectator and
just like read and
run your you know eyes over the lines
and imagine what you like in your head
but we're also supposed to be in some
respect
you could say morally engaged but not in
a moralistic
manner and i think the queen's stories
are are excellent uh with that
you know before having read these these
works
[Music]
i could say that my
you know my life could be entirely rich
and fulfilling and all that without
ged the character or tenor
or any of these these other characters
in it although those are the really the
two for me
i have to say um
[Music]
now having read them and re-read them
and gone through imaginatively
what leguin has laid out for us for them
to be
taken out of my life would be a
deprivation
and it's always kind of sad when the
story comes to an
end i had a similar experience with
reading the lord of the rings as well i
remember
being overcome by a great sadness
at the very end of it that the story had
now
come to an end which doesn't often
happen
but i does does happen for me with these
uh
earthsea stories and novels as well
so i think that's a good place to end
this little disquisition
next we'll talk about you know why she
wrote these books at the time that she
did what she has to say about them
we'll talk about world building and then
we'll get into those philosophical
themes
in lieu of providing a biography of
ursula k le guin
from her birth in 1929 to her recent
death
which we've already covered in some of
the other
earlier sessions i thought it would be
useful to talk instead just about that
that period
of her life in which she
is is working through these
three additional earth-sea books you
can't say novels because you know only
two of them
are actually novels and you know i think
a lot of this
it's good to draw directly on her own
words that she provides
in this this omnibus version and in her
interviews
because that way you know we can get
some direct insight into
what was going on i will point out she
says that she began
working on the fourth earth sea
novel which is going to become tahanu
shortly after
publishing the the third one so that's
1972
and you notice that it doesn't actually
come out until 1990 and you might say
well what is going
on there it took her a long time to
figure out precisely
what she wanted to say how she wanted
to frame these characters she's bringing
in
of course some some new characters but
she's also working with some some older
characters uh as a matter of fact older
is kind of a you know
a pun there without meaning to be so an
older ged who has been described as such
in the farther shore but also
an older tenor as well and so
you know i think it's good to like just
focus on
what's what's going on in writing these
why did she write these why did she
think that that
that needed to happen before that though
i want to bring up something that's
coming from
a particular interview that i'm going to
be drawing on
quite a bit from the 2001 sci-fi
site interview so 2001 is when
the last two books both come out
and one of the things that the
interviewer asks
is is this the telling tales from earth
sea the other wind
the birthday of the world and other
stories four
major new books in under two years
including your first
novel sense to hanu probably your most
prolific period
since the 1970s to what would you attrib
ascribe this productivity so this is
like the archetypal
where do you get your ideas from kind of
question
that she's being given here and i think
her answer is
is really quite good and telling she
says
this effective and immense
industriousness is an artifact
of the peculiarities of the publishing
industry
so it's not it's not a reality she says
i was writing about my usual rate for
some years
without being sure where to publish in
book form for various reasons
changes of editors literary agents etc
my new publisher harcourt once they got
onto me were eager to print everything i
gave them in very short order
and then my old publisher harper
suddenly decided i was still alive
so i end up with four books in two years
five counting a long delayed kids book
tom miles to come out in march
two of these new books assemble stories
i wrote in the 1990s but didn't include
in my 19
in my 90s collections a fisherman of the
inland sea unlocking the air sea road in
four ways to forgiveness
um she says similarly
uh tales from earthsea isn't a novel but
it carries the earth sea
series from tahanu to the other wind
without a break
then the other two novels the telling
and the other win came
one right after the other at the end of
the decade one came slow
one came fast and so this is a great
reflection right
why was she so productive in that period
it just happened that
publishers were ready to publish the
stuff at that time so there's no
particular
rhyme or reason to it it wasn't as if
she
suddenly had a burst of productivity at
that time she's
she's laboring constantly and i should
mention that during this this period
from the publication of tahanu to
tales from earth sea and the other wind
what we see
happening is she also publishes her
version she says it's not a translation
but rather a version of the dao da jing
she's named a living legend by library
of congress
she gives a number of different speeches
and interviews
she's by this time working within the
digital framework
and and also doing workshops for for
writers
constantly writing herself constantly
helping others to write
as well and
where should we go next i think that the
the next thing we should look at is what
she says
in her own website this is in 2001 as
well sort of a recap
on her part she says in september 2001
harcourt published the fifth novel on
the sixth book of earthsea the other
wind
and she tells us the order of the books
and then she says that they run in
chronological order both in this world
and in earthsea
a little bit further down she says when
tahani was published i put a subtitle on
it the last book of earthsea i was wrong
i really thought the story was done
tener had
finally got her second inning get and
tenar were obviously happily ever
after ever after and if i didn't know
exactly who
or what tejanu was it didn't bother me
but then it began to bother me and a lot
of things about earthy were bothering me
like do wizards really have to be
celibate if witches don't and
how come no women at rock and who are
the dragons and
where do kargish people go when they die
and
so she you know these are sort of you
know musing
questions about her secondary creation
to use a you know tolkenzian
uh word that she picks up as well in her
own her own
reflections on what it is to write
fantasy
and she says i found the answers to a
lot of these questions
in the stories that make the tales from
earthsea
so then i was able to find out who
tahanu was and who the dragons are
in the other wind so you know the the
motive for
writing these stories is not well you
know i've got some loose ends that i
need to tie
up or you know this is a fantasy world
that i made
and i think there's still some juice to
be squeezed out of the
lemon or the grapefruit or whatever
whatever metaphor we're going to use
it's more there's things that are
puzzling me and you know this reminds me
of somebody who i took
a class with actually several classes
with
back when i was in graduate school rick
williams who
was sort of a larger than life character
he taught
ancient greek at southern illinois
university
and actually i'm going to indulge a
little bit in telling this and i'll come
back to
the point so rick williams was as tall
as i am
six foot three quite an imposing figure
by that time he must have been in his
late 50s or so and he definitely was
into projecting himself in a dramatic
way i remember
the very first day of the very first
class
in ancient greek classical greek that i
was taking
uh there were 12 of us in the class and
he told us all we had to like you know
say why we were taking the class and i
was like well you know i want to read
plato and aristotle he's like
that's that's fine you know there's more
to ancient greek than that right
and then there was some kid some
undergraduate
and he said i thought it would be fun
and
williams like said fun
you greek isn't fun and he like leaned
over the kid and you can see the kids
shrinking
into the desk and williams was little
you know he gave him the
greek is maddening it's going to you
know tax you and all that and he gave
this
long essentially diatribe and then he
i remember this gesture at the very end
of it he had his like hand almost in the
kid's face
like this and he's like greek will
change your life
you know and of course we never saw that
kid after that
and there was a very high attrition rate
to that class only four of uh of the 12
finished it and then only two of us
made it through the second semester
greek
but one of the things that you did after
you finished your your original
like learning all the grammar and you
know vocabulary and stuff like that
was you would read authors and so i had
the opportunity
to do an entire semester reading through
plato's symposium in greek with with
rick williams
and he at that time had been reading the
book he said for about 30 years
and you know you would think it would
have gotten stale and he said no no i
keep coming back to it because there's
still
questions for me every time
that i'm reading it no matter how many
times i've gone through it
there's all this cool stuff happening in
it you know dirty jokes and
you know socrates responding to this but
there's still
open questions for me that i i need to
to understand and so the queen is going
through something like that
except it's not plato's symposium it's
her own works
that she has created so another
fitting place to go to is
i would say the the afterward of tehanum
she says between the last chapter of the
tombs of ottawa
second book right and the first chapter
of tehanu 25 years or so past time
enough for the girl
tenar one of the main characters of
tombs of ottawa
to become a widow with grown children
between the last chapter the farthest
shore and the fourth chapter of tehanu
a day or two passes time enough for the
dragon
kalesen to carry ged from rock to gaunt
between finishing the farther shore and
beginning to hanu 18 years of my life
passed time enough for me to learn
how to write this book and
why did she do it she says i knew
tenar's story
needed to be told that she and ged had
to be brought together so right after
finishing the third book i began the
fourth one
but though i knew tenor had not stayed
with ogian
god's former teacher write the mage on
gaunt
but had gone off and married a farmer
and lived an ordinary unmagical life
i didn't know why the story got stuck
i couldn't go on it took years
of me living my own ordinary life and a
great deal of learning how to think
about such things
mostly from other women before i could
understand why tenor did
what she did and who she was at the end
of it then at last
i could write to hanu i think that's a
very interesting
way to to explain what was going on
you know we we often think about the
writer as you know removing themselves
from their their own life and you know
buckling down and writing and some
people can do that
but that's not the way that leguin works
at these these matters as a matter of
fact she even talks in another interview
about the arrangement that she and her
husband
made in order to make it possible for
both of them to have their careers him
as a professor and teacher her as a
writer
and they and she said we realize that
two people could do three jobs the third
job being
taking care of the household cooking
cleaning taking care of the children
and you know they they had a very
productive
uh marriage and relationship in that way
there's a lot that has to go into being
able to
tell a story and so i think that's quite
an interesting
set of remarks um there's some things
i'm going to come back to
here but i do want to read a few other
things from this
this part where she's explaining
what's going on in tahanu and what what
had changed why
she's writing it so she says in both the
tombs of atawan and tahanu books in
which women are central to the story
there's a kind of anger which i don't
think is in a wizard
or the farther shorts the anger of the
underdog
fury against social injustice the
vengeful rage women
have too often been made to feel i'd
finally learn to acknowledge such anger
in myself
and to try here's a very key thing to
try to express it
without injustice and so
you know we're going to get back into
this where she talks about
how it was labeled feminist but i think
that that's an important
uh thing as well there had to be some
[Music]
some learning and articulation that that
needed to take place
and you know so that's that's some good
reflection on what's going on there
let's look as well at tails from earth c
so there's a forward to it
and there's also a um
an afterword that's that's worth looking
at
and so she she says that um
[Music]
here we go the five tales in this book
explore or extend the world established
by the first four
earth sea novels each is a story in its
own right
but they will profit by being read after
not before
the novels and she tells us you know the
finder takes place about 300 years
before the time of the novels in a dark
and troubled time
its story casts light on how some of the
customs and institutions of the
archipelago
came to be and we'll talk about that
more when we get to the world building
the bones of the earth is about the
wizards who taught the wizard who first
taught ged
and shows that it takes more than one
mage to stop an earthquake
dark rose and diamond might take place
at any time during the last couple of
hundred years in earth sea
after all a love story can happen at any
time anywhere
on the high marsh is the story from the
brief but eventful six years that ged
was arc mage
of earth sea and the last story which
takes place a few years after the end of
tehanu is the bridge between that book
and the next one the other wind a dragon
bridge and you know i'm going to look
a little bit more at what she has to say
here again in the in the world building
part but let's jump
back to the
other things that she has to say about
this
at the very end of it
so she she tells us
here we go
it would have simplified things for my
publishers and me if my the fifth book
of ersie had been a novel but it wasn't
sometimes the elements of a book won't
come together in a single story being by
nature
disparate they have to go different
places different ways one back through
the centuries
another to have nor maybe another to
symbol i couldn't write the last
earthsea novel until i'd been to islands
in times
i hadn't yet explored storytellers
stories
like scientific theories or explorations
excursions into the tremendous gap
between
almost knowing and knowing and a little
bit
later she she talks about
you know the these stories and she says
the first novella the finder is the
prequel right
it is the story behind the story of the
first
four books of earthsea and she's got
this wonderful metaphor here
writing it was really like swinging out
on a spider thread into the unknown i
had no clear idea where otter
was going when he set out into his dark
misgoverned world
i only knew he would come to rock and
find or found
the school there and she says
all of these stories are explorations of
such matters unclarities balances and
imbalances moral
choices dark rose and diamond has to do
the question of wizardly celibacy
and asks the question if you could
either do magic or make songs but not
both
which might you choose in the bones of
the earth i found out who ogion
god's teacher originally was who his
teacher was how far back
magic could and could not go on the high
marsh
let me deal with what gets left out when
magic is understood
purely as power so that's an important
theme
as well power over human to do what
save the world from your enemies is that
all is that enough
if power is responsibility for whom
are you responsible the last novella
dragonfly is the direct bridge between
tahanu and the final novel
its final events follow after the end of
tehanu and come before the other
wind everything i'd been learning about
the relationship of people
and dragons finally comes clear
in this story along with the
understanding of what had gone wrong
on rogue
you know she's saying that all of this
is allowing me
to figure out this this world that i've
been creating and who the people are and
how their lives work
and what they have to tell us or to ask
us
finally we have um
the sixth book and that's also
got as usual in the this an afterword
right the other wind as well as some
very nice illustrations
in this this volume and
she tells us here i've already read some
of this
so i'm going to skip over that she says
um
i can see in its theme that of the the
sixth volume
uh coming together from elements of all
the previous works joining forces and
playing out in a way i could never have
foreseen when i started wizard of earth
sea
even when i started the other wind all i
knew for certain was that the increasing
imbalance
in the practice of wizardry was caused
by a profound error which we're going to
talk about
shortly and she she says
um i don't and won't attempt to explain
what the book says i've been asked a
thousand times to say what a story means
every time i've grown sure as long as
i've told the story rightly finding its
meaning
or a meaning is rightly up to its its
readers
and she finishes this this forward by
saying
it has come round to and passed where it
began so long ago in that dark night on
roke
and the great sunrise in the other world
it came where it was going all along
and yet it goes on past that not being a
closed circle
but a spiral and here's a very
interesting metaphor
like the orbit of our earth lives end
lives go on a story ends others go on
i know the reign of king lebanon and
queen
sarasota will be long remembered in both
the archipelago and the car-gad lands i
think rogue will change and maybe magic
itself will change
i'm not sure if the dragons will ever
return out of the west beyond the west
yet i know tahanu will i know where ged
goes next
but a storyteller doesn't tell all she
knows
and that's that's a fitting ending
for the this entire earth c
um narration she says don't call it a
cycle but we could call it a cycle
and there's a few other things i think
that are that are worth
um looking at i i realize this is less
of a
biography and more of a uh whatever we
want to call it
an investigation of the motives of the
the storyteller
herself um but there's some other things
from this this interview
that that i brought up earlier the this
uh sci-fi
site interview that i think are quite
good so
the interviewer said the hallmark of
your work over the last decade has been
a return to revisioning of your original
highness and earth sea sequences
do you think you're finished now with
ersie and the ekimen
rounded them off conclusively leguin
says
earthsea got revisited and revisioned
and certain obscurities
were made clear now i'll also mention
because we were talking about the
highness or acumen novels in another
site she says the accumen worlds merely
got further explored it seems to me so
she's making a distinction there
she's saying yes earthsea i answered my
questions that were being
raised for me and perhaps for other
readers
as well obscurities were made clear
i brought lights and articulation to
areas that were
previously just in the dark or in the
shadow of a shadow you might say
you know so then the
interviewer goes on and says and here's
here's where um
it gets really quite interesting a
striking contrast between the original
earth sea and acumen novels
and their recent successors as the
latter's move from action to observation
the telling in the other wind are
contemplative and discursive rather than
plot driven
why is this and leguin says well i was
in my 70s
when i wrote them there's something
about one's body as it gets around 70
years old that induces
strongly often imperatively a shift from
action to observation
action at 70 tends to lead to a lot of
saying
observation however can be rewarding as
i've never been sure where my body
leaves off and my mind begins or vice
versa it seems unsurprising to me that
the condition of one of them
induces a similar condition in the other
and then she says
i've never written a plot driven novel
anyway i admire plot from a vast
distance with unenvious admiration i
don't do it
never did it don't want to can't my
stories are driven
by a different chauffeur then she says
the other wind
completes a retraction or renunciation
begun or this is actually this is the
interviewer i'm sorry
says says the other one completes a
retraction renunciation begun and tahanu
entails from
earthsea of the premises of the original
earthy trilogy magic itself is
invalidated to a great degree
how do you intend the first three books
to be read now and they're spontaneous
shall we say majesty or with a
qualification
of hindsight and here leguin gets pretty
salty
and and rightly so i mean if you think
about the the question
the um the the furthest shore is already
about a land in which magic is being
sucked out
so it's it's a bit of a a misnomer to
say
that you know you've got this original
trilogy where
all this magic and then it's being
reevaluated and
taken back in the later books because
that's already happening in the earlier
stuff
so she says the assumptions stated in
the first sentence of this question are
simply wrong
which means i can't answer but can only
retort with questions
why do you say magic is invalidated in
the last three earthsea books on what
evidence because ged can't do it anymore
one man
who gave up his power knowing what he
was doing and why has the school on rope
closed have the old powers died
are the dragons grounded is the
patterner not still in his grove
and is the grove not the still and ever
moving center of the world
all of this is there in these um later
books right i mean
we actually get to see how rogue is
being founded
in the first story in um
tales from earthsea and there's all of
this
you know conversation going on on rogue
in
the other wind so you know that's that's
kind of iffy
as a matter of fact we could say magic
in fact gets expanded we learn
more about it in the uh
the three final books
so she says i will not say how i intend
the books to be read i have and want no
control over my readers
except of course the sway of the stories
themselves different people are going to
read my trilogies different ways and
that's as it should be
because the first trilogy is more
accessible to kids
they may stop with it and then come back
when they grow up and go on with the
second set
but if the second trilogy invalidated or
retracted
or revoked the first one i wouldn't have
written it
that's not my motive she's saying the
second trilogy
enlarges the first which is very strong
but
narrow leaving out far too much of the
world
the second trilogy changes nothing in
the first it sees exactly the same world
with different eyes
this is a one a passage that's been
quoted
many times so i'm going to read this
again the second trilogy changes nothing
in the first it sees exactly the same
world with different eyes
almost i would say with two eyes rather
than one
now that's worth thinking about what
does she mean there two eyes rather than
one is this referring to the
male female duality that we'll talk
about
is it referring to understanding the
dragons in relation to human beings
is it referring to something else
she doesn't she doesn't tell us
well actually i mean she does tell us
one possible interpretation all of the
books are in large part
fictional studies of power isn't that an
interesting observation
power what kind of power the power of
magic
also the power to make people do things
power can be compelling
power can be liberating so she goes on
and she says
the first three see power mostly from
the point of view of the powerful
the second three see power from the
point of view of people who have none
or who have lost it or who can see their
power
as one of the illusions of mortality now
is that
you know is it as neatly cut and dried
is that no because
obviously we have other figures in there
like lebanon the new king
and you know the dragons uh you know so
there are um a lot of characters who who
have power
but there is an expansion taking place
here and that expansion
is the raison death you could say the
expansion
which is also an answering of questions
of you know that have been posed in the
previous
uh landscape the the earth sea that she
created
that's why these books come about and as
a result she creates
this fictional universe that is
so compelling for so many of us
so now let's explore the topic of world
building and what we're talking about
here
is an expansion of a world that has
already been
in significant part built out but is now
there to be explored to be
unpacked to have a number of different
things added to it we've got the same
basic elements in these these next three
books
as we had in the previous three we're
still looking at the same
map of earth sea we have the the
you know the people of the archipelago
in there
with with havnor in the center and the
reaches
on the outsides and the kargish lands
over to the
east and the dragons coming in
from the west and we also have
already you know developed the the dry
land
the land of the dead um where people go
to where the the far the shore took
place at the end
and all these other you know aspects of
earth see
you know a pre-industrial society
based around crafts without an awful lot
of what we can call religion
but but definitely some things of magic
of you know politics but not on
on a grand scale except at certain
points
and people living their lives
loving raising children practicing their
crafts
paying their taxes not paying them
smuggling
falling in love doing doing all the
things that that people
do but we're seeing more and more added
to
the story and i would say in these three
books
the world building that is taking place
it is of a narrative universe and
it's not just like exploring new lands
or
centering more on like the geography of
the island of gant where
you know uh ged grew up and where um
you know a lot of the action in in um
the the fourth book um is
is actually happening so
you know it's it's you could say
a further unrolling
in multiple directions of the
tapestry composed of the threads that
were started originally but now
are into a much richer composition
and i really think in talking about um
world building one of the places to
start is by looking at the the fifth
book where the queen says in her forward
a mere glimpse at earthsea told me that
things had been happening there while i
wasn't looking
it was high time to go back and find out
what was happening or what was going on
now and then she says i also wanted
information on various things that had
happened back then before gad and tenor
were born
a good deal about earthsea about wizards
roque island dragons had begun to puzzle
me
in order to understand current events
current events within earthsea right
i needed to do some historical research
to spend some time in the archives
of the archipelago now of course you
realize that she is talking about
a fictional world here so what does it
mean to do
research in the archives she goes on and
she tells us
the way one does research into
non-existent history is to tell the
story
and find out what happened so
as opposed to like going in and digging
around in archives you have to
essentially invent the archives
and she says i believe this isn't very
different from what historians of the
so-called real world do
even if we're present at some historical
event do we comprehend it
can we even remember it until we can
tell it as a story
and here it's worth pausing
and you know reiterating a point that
that we made a little bit earlier leguin
tells us that she is not a plot writer
she does not orient her stories by
coming up with a plot first and then
finding characters to fit in with them
and
you know situating them in a setting
it's rather
setting and character that are that are
driving things
instead and you could say certain ideas
as well so she goes on and she says
as for events and times or places
outside our own experience we have
nothing to go on but the stories other
people tell us
past events exist after all only in
memory which is a form
of imagination that's worth pausing on
we often picture the um
you know we picture the past as like
almost like a movie or things that that
happened
and we could have memory of that and
memory is good and imagination is where
we go wrong
and leguin actually does tell us in like
interviews for example that you've got
to be careful with the imagination
there's people that can imagine all
sorts of things that are really
implausible but can come to dominate
their their life
and she was you know saying things like
that um you know for example during the
obama year seeing the
resurgence of racism coming out
uh and she also you know towards the the
beginning of the trump year she was
still alive and talking about
this this was quite a surprise to me to
see this
coming back uh in in the way that it has
so imagination isn't always a good thing
but
properly driven uh properly harnessed it
can be
and our memories are held together
and and you know actuated you might say
by imagination which lends to them
importance which lends to them weight
so going on here she says
the event is real now but once it's then
it's continuing reality is entirely up
to us
dependent on our energy and here's a key
term
and our honesty if we let drop from
memory
only imagination can restore the least
glimmer of it if we lie about the past
forcing it to tell a story we want it to
tell to mean what we want it to mean it
loses
its reality as a matter of fact we're
going to talk about magic a little bit
later on and this one of the key
points that she makes in one of these
stories
is that power magic
by by its nature tends to be in some
ways hostile to untruth even though it
can be
used by by untruth so she says
um here we go it loses its reality
becomes a fake
to bring the past along with us in in
through time into the whole dolls of
myth and history
is a heavy undertaking but as lao tzu
says
wise people march along with the baggage
wagons so she says
when you construct or reconstruct a
world that never
existed a holy fictional history the
research is of a different order
but the basic impulse and techniques are
much the same you look at what happens
and try to see why it happens you try to
reconstruct
intelligibility you listen to what the
people there tell you
and watch what they do you think about
it seriously and you try to tell it
honestly
so that the story will have weight and
make sense
and you know so she she goes on and um
actually i'm going to skip to to the the
very
end part of that where she is uh giving
you an
afterword of this she tells us that
[Music]
for the story of earth sea to have
weight and to make sense in my own mind
so that i could take it to its end so
that i could build the bridge to true
closure
not only did i have to find out what was
going on now but i had to work
go back in time to find out what had
gone wrong and
when and how why had the wise teaching
of the balance been getting
increasingly out of balance
and um you know she goes on a little bit
more and talks about
living in the present tense of
electronic media says people who live
immersed in the ceaseless present tense
of electronic media
may have no interest in the past letting
mythology replace history as
pre-literate peoples did
but as i grew up with all the
unrearrangeable implacable durability of
print my education gave me the sense of
the past
that perceives the present only as the
bright restless surface of an ocean
so paradoxical as it may seem i didn't
want a mythology
of my mythical world but the history
of it the facts of the fiction its time
depth
which of course meant yet more
paradoxically i had to make it up
to grope blunder see if it worked and
she says oh friends
this isn't right and then she tells us a
little bit about
something that is is you know on her
part
the most explicit world building that
we're gonna find she says the
description of earth see at the end of
the tales
is a summary sketch of that history as i
worked it out while
writing the stories so if if you've read
through um her description of earth c
which is
you know it's it's just enough stuff to
get you
through what's going on and to interface
with the stories and kind of bring
everything together
in a similar way to like a more
well worked out map does compared to an
earlier
map of where everything is going on you
can see
what she's referencing there so it's
very interesting to see that her
world building there's a couple
different characteristics to it right so
there is an expansion
more characters are coming in right
we're finding out
about places that we didn't know that
much about we learned about more about
the kargish lands in
you know well both of the fourth book
and the the sixth book right because
uh tenner is is kargish herself so
there's
some memories of things that come from
you know her time in ottawa
um we learn about um
other islands and different ways
of of understanding magic and
understanding the old powers
we learn about where the dragons are we
learn about
a geography that we could call
a supernatural or whatever we want to
talk about the land of the dead
geography as well and particularly
in the sixth book so
and we learn more about rock too at the
center of
of earth sea along with with pelnor
what is going on there it's not just
sketching out all these areas and sort
of filling them in
sort of like writing encyclopedia
entries
instead all of these places are coming
about because people
are solving
or failing and and you know
screwing up moral political
metaphysical personal relationship
identity problems this is there's a
deeply philosophical aspect to this but
it's not philosophy in the sense of
writing a treatise
right instead it's it's relational with
the characters
the characters get to tell their stories
and sometimes they may be lying
sometimes they may be bullshitting
and leguin has to decide
where to put them in there how to
fit all of these people and
actions and intentions
together to to tell a a narrative
that that actually is as she's saying
honest
it may seem paradoxical to us talking
about
what honesty could there be in
fantasy in literature in
fiction but she's saying that it is
there
and that you know she remarks on this in
interviews that
um when we when we dismiss fantasy
as just something that's you know purely
of the imagination and it's not grounded
in reality she says that you know
that's a mistaken point of view and
she's actually got a great line
somewhere about you know a mature person
is not somebody who's
left the child behind but somebody who's
grown the child
into an actual adult and that a lot of
what we think of as adults are really
children who
have had to leave their their childhood
you know entirely behind as being
immature
and they didn't really get an awful lot
in the bargain
they they were given a world that we we
can look around and see
but it's in some respects
dimmer and not as rich as a world that
would would have an
openness let's say to to fantasy so
those are some some you know interesting
musings i suppose you could say on my
part
we should talk now about philosophical
themes but i think that the
the world building aspect is something
important and we could say that there's
i know this word has been abused uh way
too much
in in the last couple decades but we can
say that there's
you know for leguin there's an organic
development
of the world that she's exploring it
can't be forced
that's part of why it takes so long for
her to get back to these
and it's it's a world not where first
you have the world
and then the people you know popped into
it
rather it's a world of peoples it's a
world in which
people have have made the world it's a
world
of human agency and also
whatever we want to call the the powers
and the magic and the dragons
all of that sort of stuff it's not just
purely human agency
either we've come to the point now where
typically we discuss
a few philosophical themes having gone
through some
biographical and world building matters
and and due to my own loquaciousness we
don't have as much time as i'd like
because i always cap these
at at most 90 minutes
but i think we can at least get in a few
of the
important and interesting philosophical
themes that are that are being
addressed and being expanded
in these and so you know we'll see how
far we can get to them
the one that we might not go into as
much is the nature
of power and its relation to to magic
and
and other moral concepts but i
definitely want to talk about the
relationship that leguin reveals to us
here
between the dragons and human beings
there's there's a lot to unpack
there having to do with language the
nature of reality
uh we could call it anthropology
whatever the equivalent of that and
dragon
things would be right so
that's a key theme and then i think we
also have to discuss
i was going to say her relationship to
feminism but it might be better
described as her conception
of the relations the complex relations
between
men and women which are also embodied in
the way in which
magic is is done it's not simply
gender relations it's not simply
politics it's not simply society it
affects the nature of
magic itself and i think we can see some
parallels there
between the kind of alienation and
and distrust that's happening between
humans and dragons and that between
men and women and we can also we could
introduce that third vector of the
powerful
and the power less so let's talk about
the dragons thing
first and there's there's a number of
places
where things are are being discussed i
think one of the passages that we should
focus on right away
is in the other wind where
uh the humans are being told why the
dragons are are coming back and
attacking
them and so this is um
uh irian uh who is uh
uh ormerian now she says kellison
the eldest calls me daughter i am sister
to orm embar
whom the king knew and grandchild of orm
who killed the king's companion
eric erith abba and was killed by him
i am here because my sister tahanu
called to me tahanu
is the the raped damaged
child who's been thrown into the fire to
die who tenor
nurses back and and thinks maybe it
might have been actually more merciful
to
allow her to die tenor is
is tasked with teaching her and doesn't
really
understand precisely how to do that in
uh tahanu
so anyway coming back to this the story
that's being told
when oram embar died on cellador
destroying the mortal body of the wizard
cub this is back in the third book
calicine came from beyond the west and
brought the king and the great mage to
rogue
then returning to the dragon's run the
eldest called the people of the west
whose speech had been taken from them by
cop if you remember in the third
story cobb in draining the magic
out of things had taken the dragon's
speech away from them and the dragon
speech we should reiterate
for those who don't remember this it's
inborn
it's not something that they've had to
learn they they know the old
tongue and so
he she continues kelsen said to them you
let evil turn you into evil you have
been mad you are sane again but so long
as the winds blow from the east you can
never be what you were free of both good
and evil
kellison said long ago we chose we chose
freedom
men chose the yoke we chose fire in the
wind they chose water and the earth
we chose the west and they the east and
colesian said
but always among us some envy them their
wealth and among
them some envy are our liberty so it was
that evil came into us and will come
into us again until we choose again and
forever to be free
soon i am going beyond the west to fly
on the other wind
i will lead you there or wait for you if
you will come
so then some of the dragons respond they
say
men in their envy of us long ago stole
half our realm from beyond the west from
us
and made walls of spells to keep us out
of it so now let us drive them into the
farthest east and take back the islands
men and dragons cannot share the wind so
this is this is the dilemma that's being
posed
can these two ways of life these two
ways of understanding reality
be made compatible and then here's
here's the key
issue that le guin is introducing
coliseum said once we were one people
and in sign of that in every generation
of men one or two
are born who are dragons also and in
every generation of our people longer
than the quick lives of men
one of us is born who is also human one
of these
one is now living in the inner isles and
there is one of them living there now
who is a dragon
these two are messengers the bringers of
choice now isn't that an interesting way
to think about it all of this is being
framed
not just in terms of well you got
dragons on this side and humans on this
side
choice what is going to be done now in
this new circumstance
calisine says to uh to them come
come with me to fly to the far side of
the world on the other wind or stay and
put on the yoke of good and evil or
dwindle
into dumb beasts you have these three
choices to make and he says the last to
make this choice will be
tahanu after her there will be no
choosing there will be no way west
only the forest at roke will be in the
center
so irian then says after some years had
passed kalisin flew beyond the west
some followed some of the dragons some
did not
when i came to join my people i followed
kalesin but i go back
i go there and come back so long as the
winds will bear me the disposition of my
people the ones who have stayed
who've chosen to stay is jealous and
irate those who stayed here and the
winds of the world began to fly in bands
or singly to the aisles of men saying
again
they stole half our realm now we will
take all the west of their realm and
drive them out of it so they cannot
bring their good
and evil to us anymore they will not put
our necks into
into their yoke but they did not try to
kill the islanders because they
remembered being mad when dragon killed
dragon they hate you
but they will not kill you unless you
try to kill them
and so you know the king then says
okay what is you know
what is happening he says this in
response to irian saying they fear
nothing in the world except your
wizardries of death
and the king says what are you talking
about we we got rid of cop
i was there i was i was one of the
people who helped to do him in
and and she says we fear your spells of
immortality
and then uh onyx master onyx stands up
and says we make no spells of
immortality
only kaab sought to make himself
immortal perverting our art to do so
our archmage with my lord the king and
with the aid of orm mbar destroyed cobb
and the evil he had done
so i'm saying we've fixed things haven't
we and
um irian says the wizard that i
destroyed the summoner of rook thorian
what was it that he sought
and this is part of the story here
thorian came back
across the wall the stone wall
from the land of the dead and then tried
to take
uh you know power in in the land of the
living
so what's going on there there's there's
still an imbalance that has to be
addressed
and in order to understand this we we
can actually go
to uh tahanu there is very early on this
discussion about
what is is uh going on and there's this
story that
ogian uh has has told
right so here we go oh jin stood at the
hou
at the door of the little house by the
sea wall and an old woman opened the
door
the nogian stepped back and he held up
his oak staff and put up his hand
as if trying to protect himself from the
heat of the fire and in his amazement
and fear
he said her true name allowed dragon
there's
the dragon this is the one that's been
referenced as living there among human
beings
in that moment he he told me it was no
woman he saw at all in the doorway but a
blaze and glory of fire
a glitter of gold scales and talons and
the great eyes of a dragon
they say you must not look into a
dragon's eyes then that was gone
and he saw no dragon but an old woman
and she
he goes in she feeds him fish soup and
then
she tells him a story so here's the
story
uh here we go when segue raised the
islands of the world from the sea
in the beginning of time the dragons
were the first born of the land and the
wind blowing over the land
so the song of the creation tells this
key you know
uh story for for the the archipelago
but her song told also that then in the
beginning dragon and human
were all one they were all one people
one race winged and speaking the true
language so this is an origin story
about human beings
they were beautiful and strong and wise
and free but in time
nothing can be without becoming so among
the dragon people some became more and
more in love with flight and wildness
and would have less and less to do with
words of making
or with study and learning with houses
and cities they wanted only to fly
farther and farther hunting and eating
their kill
ignorant and uncaring seeking more
freedom and more and he's not in
she's not saying this is the the best
way to be this is just the way some of
them are
others of the dragon people came to care
little for flight but gathered up
treasure well
things made things learned they built
houses
strongholds to keep their treasures in
so they could pass all they gained to
their children
ever seeking more increase and more and
they came to fear the wild ones who
might come flying and destroy
all their deer horde burn it up in a
blast of flame out of mere carelessness
and ferocity and so
the the you know she goes on and she
says
those who had been both dragon and human
changed becoming two peoples
the dragons always fewer and wilder
scattered by their endless mindless
greed and anger
in the far islands of the western reach
and the human folk always more numerous
in their rich towns and cities filling
up the inner isles
and all the south and east but among
them there were some who saved the
learning of the dragons the true
language of the making
these are now the wizards but also the
song said there are those among us who
know
that they once were dragons and among
the dragons there are some
who know their kinship with us and these
say that when the one people were
becoming two
some of them still both human and dragon
still winged went not east but
west so these are where the other
dragons came from
on over the open sea till they came to
the other side of the world there they
live in peace great winged beings both
wild and wise
with human mind and dragon heart so this
is this is one story right and then
there's
other stories that are being told later
on
in the other wind
so there's competing narratives and each
of the narratives
helps to fill in what happened what what
drove these
people apart so here's here's another
uh story this is
um here we go
the king was speaking using his still
his skill and strength to hold these
fierce willful men and women
to one purpose let me tell you masters
of rook what i learned from the high
princess
this is the kargish princess as we
sailed here
and so he says this is her tale then
long ago the human and dragon peoples
were one kind speaking one language
but they sought different things and
they agreed to part to go different ways
that agreement was called the veteran
onyx's head went up and seppel's bright
eyes darkened
verru nadan he whispered the human
beings went east the dragons west the
humans gave up their knowledge of the
language in the making
and in exchange received all skill and
craft of hand and ownership of all that
hands can make
the dragons let go of such things but
they kept the old speech
and their wings said irian um and so
then
the patterner who's who's kargish
continues this and says the villagers of
gant
and her and her remember what the wise
men of roke and the priests of cargo
forget
yes as a child i was told this tale i
think or something like it but the
dragons
had been forgotten in it it told how the
dark folk
of the archipelago because most of the
people in the archipelago are
dark-skinned
broke their oath we had all promised to
forego sorcery in the language of
sorcery speaking only our common tongue
we would name no names make no spells we
would trust a segue to the powers of the
earth
our mother mother of the warrior gods
but the dark folk broke the covenant
they caught the language of the making
in their craft
writing it in runes they kept it taught
it used it they made spells with it to
the skill of their hands with false
tongues speaking the true words
so the kargish people can never trust
them so says
the tale and
it goes on and there's there's also you
know a
story coming from paul so they're
piecing together
this account now what was the
the primal you know spell for
immortality
that's being referenced here it's not
simply having spells it's not simply
building houses it's not none of those
things
we find out a little bit later this is
the pattern speaking again
the ancients saw that the dragon's realm
was not of the body only they could fly
outside of time it may be and envying
that freedom
they followed the dragon's way into the
west beyond the west
there they claimed part of that realm as
their own a timeless realm
where the self might be forever but not
in the body as the dragons were
only in spirit could men be there so
they made a wall this is the stone
wall in the land of the dead which no
living body could cross neither man nor
dragon for they feared the anger of the
dragons
and in their arts of naming laid a great
net of spells upon all the western land
so that when the people of the islands
die
they would come to the west beyond the
west and live there in the spirit
forever
but as the wall was built and the spell
laid the wind ceased to blow within the
wall the sea withdrew
the springs ceased to run the mountains
of sunrise became the mountains of the
night
those who died came to a dark land a dry
land
and so like it says cobb and thorian
they tried to break down that wall to
bring the dead back into life
and seppel says not until life still
like the rune masters they sought the
bodiless
immortal self yet their spells disturbed
that place the summoner said so the
dragons began to remember the ancient
wrong
and so the souls of the dead come
reaching now across the wall
yearning back to life and so now the
question is well what should be done
there is this ancient wrong that was
committed the dragons are cognizant of
that they want
a bit of you could say revenge for it
and they also fear what what the human
beings might do
next at the same time the dead are at
the wall
and you know it's it's being viewed for
the time being this is a terrible thing
but they realize that the wall actually
needs to be undone
and the dead need to be liberated and a
new way of understanding life
and death and immortality has to be
enacted and that is in fact what they do
by the
end of the story
another key philosophical theme that
ursula k le guin
is working through over the course of
her writings
and her life is relations between men
and women we can call it
by whatever we want you know the battle
of the sexes gender relations
and she does you know at times call
herself a feminist as a matter of fact
there's
a very interesting uh little
part of this death ray interview where
they say you're often described as a
feminist
writer do you think this is an accurate
assessment did you set out to be a
feminist writer
or is this opinion of you based on the
fact that you were a well-received
female author at the time when feminism
was at its height and you were sort of
co-opted by the movement so these are a
lot of different
possibilities and ursa kayla green says
i frequently describe myself
as a feminist because feminist thinking
and writing of the 60s and 70s
had a huge liberating influence on me
setting my mind free from a whole lot of
masculist
bigotries and superstitions and so it'd
be untruthful and ungrateful
not to call myself a feminist even if
the term
doesn't fully describe either my
thinking or my writing
besides when you say you're a feminist
that annoys the bigots and the old farts
and the prissy ladies so much
it's kind of irresistible so this is an
interesting
point right partly it's it's being done
to you know
outrage the bourgeoisie uh partly it's
being done
out of uh you know acknowledgement but
she's also
you know she's not endorsing uh
everything that that you could say
about feminism and as a matter of fact
in the the
afterward to hanu she says that
it's not surprising that tahanu was
labeled feminist but the word is used so
variously that it's worse than
useless if you see feminism as
vindictive prejudice against men
the label lets you dismiss the book
unread if you see feminism as a belief
in
superior properties unique to women and
expect
the book to confirm that belief you'll
find it equivocal
now that's that's kind of an interesting
point
she's not saying you'll find it wrong
you'll find it equivocal why
equivocal i would i would like to
suggest that it's in part because
it's not so simple as like men are here
and women are here
you know men are from mars women are
from venus or any of this sort of
essentialist nonsense
we see in her characters some pretty
clear
reflections on the nature of men and
women
and no one single character speaks for
leguin any more than any one character
in his novel speaks for dostoyevsky's
point of view as bach tina's so
so well argued and i think that what's
what's being you know
you can say that there are feminist
perspectives certainly and she actually
brings up something that we're going to
look at
in in just a moment she says the
conversation between tennar
and the witch moss in the fifth chapter
is a case in point
is it feminist moss is pretty
contemptuous of men in general having
been treated by them with contempt all
her life
that's all right and i find her
discussion of men's power and women's
power harsh incomplete but interesting
then she goes off into an incontory
praise of mysterious female knowledge
who knows where a woman begins or ends i
have roots i have roots deeper than this
island
and she ends with a rhetorical question
who will ask the dark its name
and then the other female character in
the the discussion tenar says i will
i've lived long enough
in the dark i've often this is leguin
saying this i've often seen moss's
rhapsody quoted with approval
tenor's fierce answer almost always goes
unquoted
unnoticed yet it refuses moss's
self-admiring
mysticism and all tenor's life is in it
a little bit later she goes on and she
says that
you know tenor is three three people
and she's sort of you know acquiring
wisdom older having made herself
responsible for a damaged and vulnerable
child she knows she's ready not for
vague
innate mystical insights but for the
wisdom she needs
and has earned and and through that
wisdom she
aids characters male and female human
and dragon
throughout the rest of the the story
that's being told in the fourth and in
the sixth book
leguin also i wanted to bring up another
thing before we look at you know the
moss's speech and some of the other
discussions going back and forth
so in her bryn mawr commencement address
she talks about um several different
things languages right
and she does again bring up
feminist authors she says i'm trying to
unlearn
lessons learned from the patriarchy
along with other lessons i was taught by
my society
particularly lessons concerning minds
work works and the being of women i am a
slow unlearner
but i love my own teachers the feminist
thinkers and writers and talkers and
poets
and artists and singers and critics and
friends then notice who she says
from woolstone craft and wolf through
the furies and glories of the 70s and
80s
i celebrate here and now the women who
for two centuries have worked for our
freedom
the unteachers the unmasters the
unconquerors the unwarriors
women who have had have at a risk and at
high cost offered their experience as
truth and it's interesting that she
brings up woolstonecraft because
wollstonecraft
is such an important early author who
then
is because of her her husband who's an
unusual
uh person with whom she finally finds
you know true love in the end
um screws up her reputation making her
inaccessible to
to um through you know societal forces
to many women who would have benefited
from her stuff woolstonecraft herself is
a powerful writer and thinker and she
also screws
up her life in in a number of ways by
not following her own
advice learning lessons the hard way and
that is what happens with with some of
these characters you know
tenor um actually reflects
that i do the wrong thing in healing and
saving and taking on
uh this this child who has been so
irrevocably
damaged wouldn't have been better just
to allow her to to die instead now i'm
trying to help her
put together a a life you know
in her anxiety in her pain in in
her uh disability and
in the fact that she's going to be
shunned by nearly everybody even though
she doesn't deserve that it's really her
her you know
abusers who deserve that and who have
the power
so you know there's there's a lot going
on here i also wanted to bring up one
other thing from this brenoir address
very quickly she she talks about three
languages
she talks about the father tongue the
language of the fathers
of man ascending man the conqueror
civilized man and she says it's not your
native tongue
it's not anybody's native tongue
including men
so then she talks about the mother
tongue which is
misrepresented by the father tongue
right using the father tongue
i can speak of the mother mother tongue
only inevitably to distance it to
exclude it it's the other inferior
it's primitive inaccurate unclear course
limited trivial banal
repetitive the same over and over like
the work
called women's work earthbound
housebound
but then she doesn't stick with just two
of these she says
right after this i'm trying to unlearn
these lessons
she talks about the third tongue
she she says in the third language my
native tongue which i will never know
though i've spent my life
learning it um is is yet another one so
there's this interaction it's no it's no
longer just so simple as men
women you know binaries there's there's
more to the picture than that and i
think that's that's reflected in her
work
i do want to say uh two other things
before we look at the anti-moss thing
and some of the other things about magic
so again in the death ray interview you
portray
men in an accurate way that few men even
succeed at they're not the caricatures
women often write
emotionally stunted annoying and
inclined to unthinking action
nor the caricatures men are prone to
writing all notions of war and conquest
and the masters have easily gained power
what gives you this insight into the
male psyche
so leguin says thank you for some much
appreciated praise
i think women look at men partly in
wonder and mystification
why ever do men act like that and partly
with the clear and partial understanding
of the interested observer
this is how men act men look at women
with the same double vision i think
the other gender's view of us can and
should be a very
valuable thing to us but often it's
clouded now notice
this ties in directly with with what's
especially what's going on in tahanu
by prejudice personal resentment the
will to dominate
fear hatred and then it's it's worthless
it can't provide us with
any useful guidance and you know we see
in her handling of these these
characters
that there are many many ways men and
women can be
and understand their relation with each
other
before we actually jump into the the uh
anti-moss discussion we should mention
that in tales from earthsea there is
this this
hand that uh is essentially women
working magic in a time when the kingdom
has
has fallen apart and and wizards
are arising there's no like one central
um
you could say ethical location for them
for training
instead it's like you know every every
man for himself and it is literally men
who are the wizards and women are just
like everybody else
essentially thralls and the hand arises
in in opposition to this is a secret
thing largely with women
now um uh otter madhu
finds his way out of uh his predicaments
and into the hands of the hand you could
say and he is there at the founding of
roke and when roke is founded
it is not a male
exclusive place and it's not a place
devoted to
celibacy either these are things that
the wizards impose upon themselves
doing something kind of similar to the
what what they did
with human beings and the dragons and
you know
the the land of the dead imposing
boundaries that don't have to be there
that are revealed to be
arbitrary you know in the end and
actually in the tales from earth sea
uh one of the with the tales is in fact
um here we go it's it's of
uh the the last story um
of a woman who goes to roque to to learn
and disguises herself the doorkeeper
allows her in
and irian gets into the you know into
rock and gets them to
sort of question what they're doing but
it's it's not all about
say representation let's you know now
bring things in
and let women be involved so let's take
a look at this this discussion right
before we jump into the chapter five
thing um there's this little discussion
about uh
magic so here we go
moss brings theroux in and she says she
was kind of there
but it was a weedling kindness and when
they were together it seemed she talked
to the child a great deal
tenor did not know what moss was
teaching her or telling her
whether she should let the witch fill
the child's head with stuff
weak is women's magic wick in his
women's magic she'd heard said a hundred
times
and indeed she'd seen that the witchery
of such women as moss or ivy was often
weak in sense
and sometimes wicked in intent or
through ignorance village witches though
they might know many spells and charms
were never trained in the high arts or
principles of majory no woman was so
trained
wizardry was a man's work a man's skill
magic was made
by men there had never been a woman mage
now we find out that this is false right
later on in you know the stories about
the founding of rogue
but here's here's the famous speech that
that moss
gives tenor says what's wrong with men
and moss says i don't know my dearie i
thought on it often i've thought on it
so this is not a just you know gut
reaction
the best i can say it is like this a
man's in his skin
see like a nut in its shell it's hard
and strong that shell and it's all full
of him
full of grand man meat man self and
that's all that's all there is it's him
and
nothing else inside tener pondered a
while and asked but if he's a wizard
then it's all his power inside his
powers himself see
that's how it is with him and that's all
when his power goes he's gone
empty nothing and a woman then
oh well dearie a woman's a different
thing entirely who knows where a woman
begins and
ends listen mistress i have roots i have
roots deeper
than this island deeper than the sea
older than the raising of the lands i go
back into the dark
i go back into the dark before the moon
i was no one knows
no one knows no one can say what i am
what a woman is
a woman of power a woman's power deeper
than the roots of trees
deeper than the roots of islands older
than the making older than the moon
who dares ask questions of the dark
who'll ask the dark it's name
and then of course we have this famous
line where tenor says
i will and if you think about what moss
is saying some of it is clearly nonsense
right there there wasn't anything before
the making there wasn't man and woman
before the making there wasn't even like
you know
the human dragon split before the the
making
uh so some of this is indeed as lagreen
is saying mystical nonsense
and a little bit later on you know
there's this this
discussion that's going on between
ged and and tennar and
get actually says all the greatness of
men
is founded on shame made out of it so
hawk the goat heard wept for ged the
archmage and looked after the goats as
well as a boy his age could be expected
to do
and um you know he he talks about
um here we go i was made molded this is
a tenor i was made molded but like clay
by the will of the women serving the old
powers or serving the men who made all
services and ways and places i no longer
uh know which then i went free with you
for a moment and with ogin but it was
not
my freedom it gave me choice and i chose
i chose to mold
myself the way that i i
want to and so this is part of what's
going on
there's a little bit discussion earlier
in this about well why
can't women supplement what
would actually what's missing with the
men why
she says why are men afraid of women and
ged says if your strength is only the
other's weakness you live in fear
yes but women seem to fear their own
strength to be afraid of themselves and
then ged says
are they ever taught to trust themselves
and
and tenor says no trust is not what
we're taught if power were trust i like
that word
if it weren't all these arrangements one
above the other kings and masters and
mages and owners
real power real freedom would lie in
trust not force
and then he says as children trust their
parents
and he says as things are even trust
corrupts the men on rock
trust themselves and one another their
power is pure nothing taints its purity
so they take that purity
for wisdom and here's where tenner says
maybe they need some women there to
point out that possibility to them
and she says i don't i don't still don't
see why if there can be she kings there
can't be
she arc mages and then there's this
discussion about male and female power
so i think that part of what's what's
going on here is leguin is offering us
a number of different possibilities and
patterns rather than saying
men you know men good women bad or men
bad women good
it really depends it meant in many
respects on what they do with their
choices
how they manage all of that and so this
is a fitting place i think to end
these discussions we didn't get to
everything that i
would have liked but i do want to try to
keep this at least close to
the the amount of time and i look
forward to discussion
after this this video premieres and
in the comments and um you know
this is this is actually a text that i'm
thinking about putting together an
entire
class on for one of the places that i i
teach
so glad to have you with me on this
excursion once again
through ursula k le guin's works and
specifically
through the last three books of earthsea
you